claro que sí es una relación muy
estrecha puesto que todas estas
temáticas medioambientales suelen ser
temas muy complejos muy complicados que
requieren de mucha explicación porque
además están llenos de tecnicismos y del
lenguaje científico que no todos
conocemos puesto que la mayoría de la
población no somos expertos científicos
así que el papel de los medios de
comunicación es por así decirlo el de
traductores de este lenguaje de la
ciencia en un lenguaje más sencillo para
que todos podamos entenderlo y la
población en general se
identifique con estas temáticas de tanta
importancia los temas ambientales no
solo hablan de la salud de nuestro
planeta de nuestro planeta la salud de
nuestros ecosistemas de los recursos la
disponibilidad de aire de agua limpia
para respirar o beber sino que nos
afecta a todos los ambientes de nuestras
vidas como ya bien lo decía nos afecta a
nuestra salud tener aire y agua limpia
que respirar o que beber afecta a lo que
comemos tener suficiente
disponibles suficientes
pescados en los peces en el océano que
sean explotados de manera sostenible y
todo esto tiene que ver con cómo
hablamos de nuestro planeta y como
informamos eso si tenemos que hacerlo de
una manera equilibrada entre no inculcar
el miedo pero recordar la importancia de
cuidar estos ecosistemas y hacerlo y ya
terminó
hablando sobre todo de no solo las
crisis y los problemas que son graves
sino también de las soluciones que son
muchas y en esta conferencia las están
dando